we stand up and we will not stop
until the world sees it too
I remember that movie that's actor a
monolith Stenberg she starred in the
powerful 2018 film The hate U give it
was about a teenage girl who witnesses
the killing of her childhood best friend
by a police officer that was based on
the New York Times best-selling novel by
author that's Angie Thomas and now
Thomas's second novel on the come up
it's called also based on another
bestseller has been turned into a film
Angie Roland with the films on our
streaming service Paramount plus it
tells the story of an aspiring 16 year
old rapper her name is Bree and in this
scene Bree talks with her mom about
trying to follow in her late Father's
Footsteps and make it as a hip-hop
artist here's a look
when you were little you used to turn
everything into a microphone
you know that
if I couldn't find my hair brush I knew
you were babbling into it somewhere
your daddy would say our little miracle
gonna be a superstar
everybody just wants me to be like that
could be
could just be you it's all the special
you need
all the special you need Angie Thomas
we're happy to say is also one of the
film's producers shouldn't she be a
producer Nate she wrote the book
so congratulations with your producer
hat thank you but one of my favorite
lines in the movie Bree who spells her
name Bri you always say you can't spell
brilliant without first spelling Bree
that's it I love that line so brie is an
aspiring rapper you know who else was an
inspiring rapper you Angie Thomas so are
you really Bree well you know I took a
lot of my own personal experiences and
put it in debris at 16 I wanted to be a
rapper because it was a great way to
make myself heard but at the time my
family was struggling financially my mom
had unexpectedly lost her job and it
threw us in a tailspan and so I thought
what's the great way to make it as a you
know as a young person maybe as a rapper
maybe that's the way I can you know help
my family financially and for so many
young people that's what gravity that's
what they're pulled towards hip-hop and
wanting to be a rapper that's why they
want to do it they want that Financial
stability yeah you talk about women in
being in the Forefront of hip-hop and
not often getting the credit yes is this
is this your way maybe of changing that
narrative I hope so I think about the
women who've inspired me through hip-hop
I think about the Missy Elliots the tlcs
I think about the Lauren Hills the Nicki
Minaj's and I think about the fact that
they don't get enough props they don't
get enough credit for what they're doing
for what they've done for how they've
also empowered and inspired and I hope
that this movie makes people think about
that a little bit more you know women
have been the foundation of hip-hop but
women have been so disrespected in
hip-hop that's a fact now speaking of
women in hip-hop Rhapsody was part of
this project and kind of giving Jamila
the the energy she needed to embody what
it means to be a real Lyricist because
Rhapsody is yeah what did that mean for
you this is jamila's first role too I
think that's interesting yeah yeah well
Rhapsody the way that happened is so
funny because I mentioned her in the
book in 2018 and she reached out to me
and she was like oh I heard you
mentioned me that's so dope but like
yeah I'd love for you to be a part of
the movie and then here we are years
later she ends up not only just being a
part of it she wrote the raps in the
movie so I was amazed but for Jamila
how'd you find her Jamila was found
through over 200 audition tapes when I
found her in 200 tapes she watched all
of those tapes and she found Jamila and
immediately she just jumped off the
screen and I got a chance to see her
audition tape and I was blown away and
you know it's good when the author
forgets that this person is playing a
character that's created she impressed
you that she impressed me that much I
was like oh she's really this is brief
you know so and you mentioned sanasana
Lathan who also plays the mother but
this is her directorial debut talk about
that that's you know I've always been a
huge fan of hers from Love and
Basketball I still have my VHS tape I
should have got her decided but I've
always been a huge fan of her work and
when I found out she was interested in
directing it I was like whoa you know
I'm used to her as the actress and then
I hear she wants to play Bree's mom as
well I was all on board but then getting
to talk to her and hear her vision for
it her passion for it you see it on
screen you see it in everything she's
doing with it but to hear her talk about
it beforehand before I ever got a chance
to see her work I knew immediately I was
like I'm putting this baby in the right
hand she's going to get this kid to
Howard hip-hop is very layered there's a
need for all types of stories to be told
yes oftentimes I get caught up with
listening to lyrics but other people
they love the ratchet stuff but there's
an important factor in this movie that
you're focusing on not having to be a
killer not having to sell drugs not
having to talk about the cars clothes
and the girls yes why was that important
that was important because I want young
people to know that's important you know
we have to stand in our authenticity as
artists I'm all about being your
authentic self I'm all about speaking
your truth standing in your truth as
somebody who's had her Books banned all
over the country I'm all about standing
in your truth regardless of how it makes
people feel so I want more young people
to do that I want more young people to
stand in their authenticity because
that's truly at the end of the day what
hip-hop is really about it's about being
your authentic self yeah speaking of
authentic self that's you Angie Thomas
so good to see you again can you still
wrap do you still oh
I do I I only do it when I'm doing book
events so it's like okay I impressed
people I was surprised they were like oh
you're good so it was like no fallacies
are spit maladies causing fatalities and
do it casually damaging rappers without
bandaging them managing managing my own
labor my own salary and actually
factually there's no empty that's as bad
as me
drop the microphone Angie Thomas
congratulations on the come up what is
on the come up mean quickly it means
you're on the verge of breaking down I'm
ready seeing your dream come true on the
come up Premiere today that was really
good on Paramount plus and Insulin off
the top of your head but I said forget
it